[Música]
bueno agradezco mucho al equipo de ted
por esta invitación y estoy muy contento
y muy agradecido estar aquí presentando
les este gran camino que decidí recorrer
junto con rápido pero también un camino
que me lleva a un poco más atrás de mi
infancia recuerdo que de chiquitito
siempre quise ser basquetbolista ahora
mi obsesión
quería estar literalmente en la nba y
jugar como jugado en estos locos ganar
partidos como ganaban estos locos y
desde chiquitito siempre pertenecía a
los equipos de mi colegio represente a
mi departamento en baloncesto incluso
tuve la oportunidad de jugar alguna vez
en eeuu
pero supongo que no era tan bueno como
pensaba que era de pronto no era tan
alto como pensaba que era o tal vez no
tan talentoso como pensaba que era
entonces el sueño tuvo que emigrar a un
segundo sueño que se volvió algo que
empecé a palpar que se podía volver muy
relevante y ese segundo sueño se volvió
el sueño de pertenecer y crecer con las
grandes corporaciones del mundo entonces
estamos hablando de los dueños del
consumo masivo estamos hablando de las
personas que hacen que el 95% de las
cosas que nos metemos a la boca
manejamos o leemos vemos sean dueños de
estas y como no admirar los que nos
enseñaron que es el marketing hoy por
hoy que es el consumo y por hoy y siguen
dándonos cátedra de cómo hacer las cosas
no sólo a nivel de mercadeo sino a nivel
de generar empresas recursos humanos
finanzas cualquier cantidad de cosas
dentro de mi camino tuve la oportunidad
de pertenecer a maravillosas empresas de
las cuales estoy supremamente agradecido
la oportunidad de trabajar
johnson johnson tuve la oportunidad de
trabajar con un grandísimo cual aquí en
colombia al cual estoy bastante
agradecido y tuve la oportunidad de
pertenecer también a una gran
corporación líder en belleza en el mundo
como l'oreal donde tuve la oportunidad
de trabajar en mercadeo pero también
aparece aprender algo de administración
por categorías aprender algo de 3
marketing algo de comercial
y todo parecía bien encaminado el tema
va bien en popa viento en popa la
carrera iba creciendo y me empecé a
obsesionar con este sueño de que si ya
no iba a llegar a la nba pues iba a
poder llegar a los recuadros de una de
estas compañías y se volvió nuevamente
una nueva obsesión que empecé a tener en
mi cabeza hasta que un día
en un congreso no como este por supuesto
pero también muy importante toda la
oportunidad de conocer a unas personas
que no habían iniciado con un
emprendimiento que ya va como nos decían
nuestras compañeras se está
revolucionando las cosas las formas las
que hacemos las cosas
vieron mi presentación y se acercaron a
mí a decirme
o sea están muy interesados en que
puedas pertenecer al equipo vamos mucho
se habla de las personas que estamos
dentro de corporaciones muchas se hablan
o que estábamos mucho se habla de estos
emprendedores maravillosos gente con un
cambio de chip total que no le da miedo
arriesgar que no le da miedo caerse y
levantarse pero poco se habla de estos
intra emprendedores que tenemos una
carrera o que estamos tratando de
desarrollar cosas por un lado donde
afortunadamente las cosas pueden ir
funcionando para tomar una decisión que
de la noche a la mañana puede
representar el cambio de rumbo más
abrupto que puedes tomar en tu carrera y
recuerdo que puntualmente estas personas
me dijeron se basa estamos interesados
de que pertenezcas al equipo
pero queremos advertirte que esta es
binario
binario mira esto es un 1 o un 0
aquí o te metes y tenemos algo muy
especial que puede realmente generar un
impacto en las economías que estamos
viviendo en latinoamérica o puede ser un
0 le aposté una idea de negocio pero por
cosas de la vida algo no estábamos
haciendo bien y esta idea tuvo que
fracasar
se imagina en mi decisión
estaba con el diablito con el angelito
realmente no sabía con el diablito él
sabía que el angelito
y entrando como a tomar ese riesgo y es
una invitación también a los sueños
están pero hay que ver que está detrás
de ese sueño que lo que queremos
construir detrás de ese sueño el sueño
tal vez no se llamaba ganar una final de
la nba el sueño tal vez no se ganaba no
se llamaba estar en un head water de una
compañía en el país donde donde fue
fundada tal vez el sueño podría empezar
a migrar hacer algo mucho más
transformador algo mucho más exponencial
algo que pudiera cambiar realmente la
forma a la que estamos haciendo las
cosas hay un texto bastante interesante
de un columnista un reportero
argentinos llamar manca si hay alguna
vez tuvo la oportunidad de dar una una
charla ted y este loco lo que decía era
escribir un artículo que se llama messi
es un perro
y el tipo dentro de una maravillosa
narrativa dice
hay que ser muy afortunado
para que te guste tanto un deporte y ser
contemporáneo de su mejor época
vivir en barcelona
y que al mismo tiempo el camp nou de que
a tres cuadras de distancia
en ese tema dije hay que ser de pronto
muy afortunado para poder ver esto tan
especial poder hacer parte de este
camino
y que de paso los locos que crearon esta
idea te estén diciendo queremos que
participes con nosotros
y me fui a casa me fui de cabeza me tiré
al vacío tirarse al vacío de hecho uno
de los valores corporativos de la
compañía donde estoy en este momento que
se llama rapid no pretendemos tenerlo
todo resuelto antes de que el de que el
tema funcione si tú pretendes tenerlo
todo resuelto antes de lanzar algo y es
probable que nunca lo lance eso es
probable que siempre estés teniendo
temor del error que pudiste haber
cometido en alguna de las estimaciones o
de los cálculos que hiciste el tema es
lánzate al vacío no todo tiene que estar
calculado voy aprendiendo en el camino
conforme crece y esto es algo que spider
angular de los valores y la cultura la
corporal de la compañía y es algo que
caló en mí de forma bastante importante
porque porque me di cuenta que adicional
a muchas cosas que les voy a mostrar
estos locos encontraron la forma de
volverle tiempo a las personas el tema
de la rookies es maravilloso conseguir
relación te ahorras una pelea pero
también miremos todos los mecanismos que
tenemos para ahorrar tiempo y para
aprovechar ese tiempo de algo que
realmente importante para nosotros
y que realmente importante poder
aprovechar los momentos de ocio que
tenemos para hacer lo que realmente
agrega valor a nuestras vidas tenemos
una economía latinoamericanas que cada
vez están creciendo más y vamos a menor
ritmo que otros países pero seguimos
creciendo y lo curioso de los
crecimientos económicos es que en la
medida que las ciudades o las personas
son más pobres pues tienen el mismo
tiempo o de pronto más tiempo pero ese
tiempo no lo gastan en el mismo ocio que
tiene una persona que tiene un poco más
de ingresos porque porque no tienen
dinero para gastarse muchas de las cosas
no tenemos no no tenemos dinero para
gastarnos en muchas de las cosas en la
medida que crecemos nuestros ingresos
tenemos ya la posibilidad o el abanico
se nos amplía para gastar ese dinero en
muchas otras nuevas formas de hacer ocio
y cuando yo tengo más dinero para gastar
en cosas para hacer ocio pues el dinero
el tiempo disponible para hacer las
cosas que realmente son importantes para
mí pues se limitan entonces cada vez que
yo puedo aprovechar para devolverle
tiempo a la gente él se vuelve algo que
se vuelve piedra angular dentro de cada
una de las personas
lo más interesante que estos locos
habían encontrado
cómo romper las barreras que hacían que
el e-commerce no creciera en nuestros
países y las barreras son básicamente
tres la primera barrera es que las
plataformas de navegación en
latinoamérica y como buenos
latinoamericanos no eran plataformas
propias o no eran plataformas adaptadas
a lo que nosotros o las necesidades de
nuestros países sino que eran
plataformas traídas de ambas son traídas
de ebay de formatos que ya conocíamos
que sabíamos que habíamos sido exitosos
pero que son formatos donde una compra
de un ítem de altísima exploración como
un televisor como un reloj como un sofá
se te vuelven bastante fáciles ya lass
ya sabes que quieres comprar vas y lo
compras de pronto con un menor precio
porque te ahorras toda la operación
detrás del retail
pero cuando quieres hacer una compra de
15 20 25 productos un antojo que te
lleguen 25 minutos realmente los
procesos actuales tecnológicos no
estaban dando la talla a las necesidades
reales de los latinoamericanos
el segundo punto es cuántos de ustedes
no tuvieron honor al cielo en alguna vez
un pedido por internet y le decían te lo
entrego entre las 4 y las 8 de la noche
del día siguiente
quédate esperando entre 4 y 8 de la
noche del día siguiente que te entreguen
tu televisor si no estás te lo dejan en
la puerta si te dejan la puerta vamos a
ver si sigue ahí cuando llegues
entonces realmente lo que encontramos
también es que se manejan inventarios lo
que rápido así hay altísimos costos del
delivery
hay una baja infraestructura a nivel
latinoamérica y por supuesto hay una
débil experiencia de usuario y en el
tercer punto es algo bastante importante
y es que sólo con se dieron cuenta que
el 61 por ciento de las personas no
están bancarizadas no tienen ni siquiera
una tarjeta de crédito no tienen dinero
plástico entonces en la medida que tú
sigas manteniendo el ecommerce a
personas que sólo tienen dinero plástico
y estás hablando de un tamaño de mercado
de este tamaño y no de un tamaño de
mercado mucho más amplio a una población
en realizada se rápida entendió esto y
acepta pagos con dinero en efectivo para
que vean un poquito la plataforma y los
que no la conocen les muestro como aquí
te traemos el mercado a la palma de tu
mano simplemente arroja los productos a
tu canasta y disfruta recorriendo
nuestra tienda pide desde un chicle
hasta todo tu mercado mensual
revisa tu canasta
para contar que tal objetivo uno de
nuestros rapid tenderos te lo llevará en
minutos
y si necesitas algo más pídele lo que se
te antoje el rap y tendero siempre
estará a tu orden
somos radio y corremos por ti
[Música]
esto y estoy corremos por ti oh los
productos que vendemos encontramos que
empezamos vendiendo productos de almacén
o productos de supermercado también
teníamos restaurantes pero nos dimos
cuenta que si queríamos realmente crecer
teníamos que salirnos de esas dos
solamente y teníamos que empezar a
ofrecer mucho más servicios y para
ofrecer mucho más servicios entonces el
rap y ustedes pueden pedir dinero en
efectivo entonces pueden pedirle rap y
tendero que les lleve 300 mil pesos a su
casa pues imagínense cuántas veces no
necesitamos tener dinero en efectivo que
por no salir por peligro por cualquier
cosa o en una fiesta haciendo la vaca
con los amigos no teníamos dinero en
efectivo pero por rápido ya nos escucha
que usted no tenga dinero para la vaca
tenemos algo que se llama rap y antojo y
rápida entonces algo que literalmente
ustedes pueden pedir lo que quieran
y nos han pedido unas cosas cada vez que
colombia nos piden que colombia haga gol
eso obviamente no va a pasar
o quisiera aunque faltará más a menudo
ahora tuviéramos el poder de que eso
pasará pero hemos tenido casos donde hay
chicas que están en su peluquería tienen
un matrimonio a las 8 de la noche son
las 5 de la tarde por alguna razón de la
vida una mujer no puede ir con el mismo
accesorio del matrimonio anterior o de
todo tres matrimonios anteriores un
nuevo matrimonio les tienen que comprar
un nuevo accesorio estas chicas llamo
pidió un rap y le dijo vaya sara tome la
foto de 56
5 o 6 collares que usted vea y yo le
digo cuál me gusta y me lo compré me lo
trae y los antojos que nos han pedido le
digo imagínense todo lo que ustedes
quieren comprar el antojo que ustedes
quieran y que se los lleven a la casa si
te vuelve una fundamentación mariachis
amperio bueno cualquiera último nos
pidió hacer un poquito un ensayo sobre
la tolerancia de 1500 palabras
hace mucho lo que es que el equipo que
elegimos de ahí hacia lo que no está
pero bueno tenemos que enfocarnos en
otras cosas y tenemos otra cosa que se
llama el rap y favor el rap y favor
ustedes pueden alquilar una obra de una
persona por 7 mil 500 pesos
imagínense ustedes qué harían con una
obra de una persona por 7.500 pesos los
casos que nosotros hemos visto es que el
pasear el perro
hazme la fila del concierto
los muchachos en barranquilla estaban
jugando un torneo de play station un
cuadrangular eran tres amigos y pidieron
rapid él era porque jugará con ellos
desde el cuadrangular
el tipo llegó el rap y tendero llegó con
su cerveza con sus ex pac de cerveza a
jugar con ellos y pues de una vez unos
amigos y siguió jugando ahí le pagaron
las tres horas que el tipo
entonces imagínense lo que ustedes
pueden hacer también con este tipo de
servicios ahora sí tenemos esto podemos
convertirnos en algo que es bastante
importante que es la tienda del todo y
en la medida que nos convertimos en la
tienda del todo pues tienen muchas más
opciones y realmente necesitas un lugar
donde esté todo y no varios lugares
donde encuentres cada cosas individuales
y esto se complementa con un modelo de
economía colaborativa donde esto es
maravilloso porque lo que nosotros
tenemos un modelo como wear pues tú
haces el pedido acá el pedido lee una
vega y les llega a unas personas que
llaman rap y tenderos que están en su
bici o están en su moto estas personas
reciben el pedido el algoritmo les
indica dónde tienen que comprar ese
pedido de forma que sea más eficiente lo
compran y te lo llevan tú pagas
exactamente lo mismo que hubieras pagado
si hubieras ido al retail con un costo
del domicilio que vale 80 centavos de
dólar un poquito menos derecho 70
centavos de dólar entonces es bastante
interesante y estos locos como ganan
ganan la propina y ganan el costo del
domicilio rápido como gana
sesiones que tenemos con nuestros
aliados comerciales
con esta idea de negocio no fuimos algo
súper especial y fue que participamos de
guays combinator para los que no conocen
guay convinieron es la aceleradora de
estados más grande del mundo me ha
salido bien venga y salió netflix de ahí
salió team the air de ahí salieron
cualquier cantidad de estas grandes
empresas y rapid y casualmente se
convirtió en la
el startup latinoamericano de mejores
resultados en la historia de silicon
valley en la historia de white
combinator y obviamente tenemos unas
personas detrás que invirtieron un
dinero importante dentro de rapid
grandes nombres de fondos de inversión
que hacen que hoy rápido ya esté en
colombia pero también esté en mexico y
tengamos unos planes de expansión
bastante interesantes con un poco menos
de 15 meses desde que fuimos fundados
entonces esto es realmente bastante
interesante y una cuña y es que no nos
debe dar miedo mostrarle al mundo que en
latinoamérica también hay talento y que
nos deben de dar miedo a mostrar el
mundo que aquí también puedo ver cunas
tecnológicas de emprendimiento bastante
importantes
ahora que queremos ya a nivel mayor
apropiarnos de lo que es la localización
más importante del mundo es que queremos
estar en todos los celulares en el home
principal de cada uno de los celulares y
esto se vuelve una ambición para
nosotros
es ahí donde digo me volví a poner los
tenis
siento en la misma emoción que tenía
cuando tenía 11 años que me ponía los
zapatos e iba a meter una cesta ahorita
creyendo genuinamente que tenemos la
oportunidad de convertir algo muy
especial
que pueda cambiar la historia del
comercio en nuestros países y que sea
una compañía latinoamericana apoyado en
un esquema de personas bastante
especiales donde se generan puentes
entre las sociedades a través de los rap
y tenderos
y donde le entregamos a la gente tiempo
que pueden aprovechar en lo que
realmente es importante para ellos
aún nos queda muchísimo por construir
por construir lo decimos con muchísima
humildad
pero también sabemos que lo mejor está
por delante muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]